towards college basketball analyst if
he's open on the basketball floor don't
throw in the ball he can't shoot
managing editor of the athletic college
basketball let's welcome in you were
terrible I made a few before the cameras
are on me and yeah but Paul II said to
you right before the cameras came on
what did he say to you you miss eight
shots in a row which is worthy of
profanity in a big group of guys who
have done the same I appreciate we we've
done that Peter King we can say to Peter
five seconds before we come back on the
air Pete your microphone is live and
it's hot and that camera is coming back
don't say anything and then Peter will
say something and then he'll go you
didn't tell me and I go Pete I tell you
all Chris Simms did it as well all right
so I'm in good company this oh boy it's
very weird for us to be hanging out with
that former presidents around usually I
don't
I thought maybe Jimmy Carter would be
here waiting for us yeah or brocco
bomber awesome don't get me wrong but
whenever Seth and I get together there's
usually a president India in the
audience different yes yes we love you
whole question which of the final four
coaches needs a title for their legacy
the most out of these four guys for
their legacy remember the final four
teams again that's a great question
needs based on what I know of these guys
process I would say to them this might
surprise you I would say is oh I know
how important it is to him to win that
second it's like when you win that first
and it was long as the 19 years ago you
know and I know how he's been to the
Final Four a lot and not won it and then
you know what he went through him and
what the school went through I mean
there are very few relationships in all
of Kyle
sports between Thomas like the one
between Tom Izzo at Michigan State
University he took all that very very
personally and still carries a lot of
pain from that frankly so are you
talking about the Holden as an answer
thing and everything all the fallout
from it wasn't obviously involved in
that part of it so I know how important
it's like when you win that first one
you want the second one so badly
I just think Bruce Pearl would need it
more than anybody well you know there's
need and there's want I mean you know he
is infinite to some you know walking out
of here and you know with what he went
through it at Tennessee I don't know I
mean listen I mean winning a national
exam I'm you can say about the same
thing about Tony Bennett I heard you
talking about you know well I mean what
a story that would be from what happened
it's already an unbelievable story yeah
and the way you know I said to him that
as as sad as I was that had happened to
him I'm glad if it had to happen to
somebody it was him because he was kind
of a face of college basketball in that
moment after the game and the way that
he handled it his players have handle
that they take every question but does
he want to be the face of college
basketball now does he's a shy guy he is
doesn't he's not a media darling he is
not I don't know if we've had him on and
I remember doing one of his games when
he was playing for his coach oh wow
his dad at Butler how about that
Wisconsin Green Bay against Butler and I
remember with him in the NBA being
around his father and he doesn't do many
interviews all the more reason why I'm
glad it was him because I don't know how
many people who could have handled the
that moment with the grace that he did
you know he doesn't want the spotlight
he doesn't he's polite he's a gentleman
and when you get him as a media guy he's
great it's just and he's not he's not
never big timing you he's almost like
about the program it's about the kids he
just wants the coach was you know 1950s
movie or something yeah but you know I
always appreciated Tony the way he
played he was very good player played in
the NBA
Chris beard of Chris beer he just signed
a contract extensions how about that
last year it's not good time it must
mean he's not going any it's not good
timing it must means not take another
job right NATO it sign an extension he
had that
for like 40 hot would he be if he would
if he won Monday night who crispier yeah
well III joke with the the contractor
consented but we all know that doesn't
mean anything right that's the job okay
yes just to make sure I'm mr. Lee it's
6:00 a.m. and LA time and my body clock
right now he's hot anyway
Texas Tech he's a Texas Tech no
disrespect they go to the Elite Eight
last year they lose for starters and he
takes him to the final floor he's been a
d1 head coach for four years but he's
home you know I mean he does he could
stay at Texas Tech for a long time well
he was there under Bob Knight for right
a decade many years yeah his daughters
are he must like I mean he must like
that area there yeah he does and he's
got his daughters live there so that was
a big reason why he left you and Almeida
to go to Texas Tech and you know listen
he's shown that you can win there and
you'll say well he should get what other
job you know I mean he probably could
have had UCLA I know they reached out to
him there was communication okay explain
those two yes if you're UCLA and you're
going after John Calipari okay okay how
does it how does it get to the point
where they offer him a contract
well they formally asked Kentucky to
speak with Calipari so that step had to
be taken before the little conversations
could could take place all these other
guys they've sort of reached out to
through the search firms and the back
channels and the money guy and the Bob
Meyers and the this guy like it's all
kind of but the Calipari discussions
were very direct and very substantive
now how close did he really come to
saying Ayers probably not very you know
Cal wears his heart on his sleeve
wouldn't it help if they gave him more
money than he was making a Kentucky son
well listen by UCLA standards they broke
the bank I mean you sillies infamous
remember John John would never made more
than thirty to five that's thousand by
the way nine million so they've they
have historically traditionally had the
like you should be paying us to coach
here and so for them to get six years
forty eight million that's that's a lot
of scratch in most places now a kentucky
a little bit different cost of living
lexington to LA I understand but but
their pitch to him was more you know
just by coming here we'll build a statue
of you and in some ways being in LA is a
little more suited to his personality
it's the sports town pro sports town so
like they they're not so they love UCLA
when you win they'll hang a banner if
you want a championship otherwise
they'll just go pick on Luke Walton
pressure is the the thing that would
have let had him leave lucky because he
he's supposed to win championships UCLA
they're happy if you're mentioned as the
possible to you know championship yeah
13 yeah it's it's interesting like UCLA
and they have the same high expectations
but they don't have the same investment
on the part of the fans they barely show
up to the big games you know they come
late because they're all surfing at
Kentucky your own it's the only show in
town I mean what he's done at Kentucky
is astounding if anybody could look at
his record at Kentucky and think somehow
they're not measuring up and I don't
know where we got to this point in the
narrative that just because you have
players who are going to be drafted high
that means that they know how they win a
college game today like this whole thing
about like Duke and the whole
one-and-done thing you know so last year
Grayson Allen takes a shot at the end of
regulation that goes around the rim
twice and falls out if that drops Marvin
Bagley's in the Final Four does that
change the one in Dunn narrative this
year they take Michigan State the Big
Ten champs to the last possession they
lose on an accidentally made free throw
they lose by one point if they win that
game all of a sudden one-and-done is
validated again well well they won in
2015 that was four years ago like what's
Coach K doing so my point is that if
anybody could look at John Calipari
record and say somehow it's lacking then
you need to completely reset your mind
frame yeah but he is the one who was
instilled in reminded us of hey look at
all these guys and look at the talent
and look at all the billions of dollars
my players yes you know have have earned
he's a way station for them yes I know I
think he's a better coach if he had
players who were there for two or three
years then he is with the one-and-done I
know that he welcomes the one-and-done
and you have to have that mindset to
welcome that him them in I don't think
he I don't think their showcases his
coaching talents when he has just you
know these kids who were just passing
through it's you know again this word
coaching right it's to me that takes
place over time so yes you know
you don't have the opportunity the
problem with building these rosters that
these guys get into they have a lot less
control over their rosters than people
realize
obviously ideally you have a couple of
guys you'd have a zine you'd have an RJ
and then you'd have a Quinn cook and an
Emil Jefferson and guys who are maybe
good enough to kind of be pros but are
older you know and create that the
problem becomes players don't want to
stay around long enough to play that
role so you have to pretty much get
lucky like but like Villanova with their
older roster
I don't think Jay Wright would take side
Williamson and RJ Barrett right so they
built and there's only five to seven of
those guys every year there aren't that
many of those guys it's three Michigan
State
you know ESO doesn't get the one and
doner but he that doesn't mean he's not
recruiting them well he's lost all those
guy he lost
Okafor he lost a bar he just lost Vernon
Carey to Duke I mean everybody everyone
say what Coach K changed his flooding
and change his philosophy ever
he always recruited those guys he just
started getting them so my point is that
when you have those guys on your roster
they gotta play most of the minutes they
gotta take most of the shots and other
guys don't want to play complementary
roles or stick around to their junior
and senior year and be those guys so you
kind of have to pick one way or the
other but again I mean Kentucky lost in
overtime in the Elite Eight and York
lost by a point and it's now lost they
lead eight two years in a row they both
want championships with one and done
rosters they both come to the Final Four
yeah so they look at that and say
somehow they're underachieving I guess
maybe I'm missing something
you said Davis CBS sports college
basketball analyst managing editor of
the athletic college basketball but I
can also look at this and say did Coach
K have the right roster in place having
zion and rj barrett that you you this is
a perimeter game it's become even more
so a perimeter game each year did he
have the right team surrounding them you
know he had the best team that he could
get under the circumstances when you're
losing three and four can't you find an
outside shooter who might not be a one
and done easier said and done easier
said than not I'm telling you because
they have to be able to play I mean you
understand that he knows this right like
he can look at a see him say boy it'd be
nice if we had a knockdown shooter some
of these guys didn't pan out Alex
O'Connell Jackie I will look great in
the first couple of games
and then he went over like 2019 he
missed 129 three-pointers in a row so
you know and an ensign and an RJ as
talented as they are and as much
potential as they have they are
underdeveloped they're 18 and 19 and
there's only so like what she said she's
gotten good at and Calipari is really
good at this is there's only so much you
can teach these guys yeah in a seven or
eight month period so let's teach them
what they're capable of learning and
again like well did he have the right
roster is nice if you had another suitor
they won what 31 games I think they want
they lost like five or six games all
year half of them are without Zion I
think only one of them they lost two
games all year at full strength and they
lost by one point and the elite I think
there was no secret I said if you can
keep them on the perimeter they don't
make free throws and they don't shoot
well and they're gonna get stung in the
tournament like is there argue against
myself they're very fortunate even just
to be absolutely they should have lost
the Central Florida for sure absolutely
yeah
Zion Williamson and JAMA rant would you
say yes those are the top two yes no
question and then everybody else fault I
still think RJ's gonna go third yeah
John Moran is really special and it
really wasn't until that Marquette game
and it's not because of how good of a a
team Marquette is which obviously they
are it was the circumstances it was the
stage it was the five been watching them
all year I'm like look I called Gumby
and his athletic
and so he steps up not only in
competition but now like he knows
everyone's watching him for they've
heard about him and for him to perform
the way that he did under those
circumstances to me shows shows me what
that what's going on up here is it's
pretty special so yeah we've had this
question here the last couple of days I
don't know how it emerged but the most
talented player in Duke history mm-hmm
and it feels like we're pushing Laettner
to the side he's the most accomplished
but again yet you have to define the
word tell we're defining talent exactly
so how you tell me how are we defining
talented
I think it's athleticism is what we're
trying to do because now we're trying to
make the argument Sion is the most
talented player that Duke has ever had
but if I'm saying total game I'm taking
Grant Hill yes Jay Williams had a chance
to be a
special player there do I mean late nerd
to me it depends on he doesn't jump over
people
he's not gonna blow by you but if there
was a game on the line and you said I
can have Laettner or I can have Zion or
Grant Hill or any but I take I'd take
Laettner over anybody in modern college
basketball history with a game on the
line right yes i define the word talent
a lot more broadly than another people I
mean I think what I just said about JA
like the fact that he was able to bring
that intensity without overdoing it that
to me is a talent so up here is a talent
your work ethic is a talent your
consistency is a talent your energy is a
talent your ability to perform under
extreme pressure is a talent so and
again we say in Duke history are we
talking about while they were a Duke or
what they did in the NBA or their
potential because you can make a case
that Kyrie is and in that case that Duke
yes if I'm saying I mean certainly the
most accomplished the best player in the
history of Duke is Christian laner I
don't think you can even argue otherwise
when you the talent I think as you're
defining it I would lean more towards
Grand Hill I would put Bobby Hurley in
that in that category as well I mean
unbelievable quickness toughness
decision-making you know setting the
tone Johnny Dawkins comes to mind Johnny
Dawkins I'd put in there before Hurley
big-time big-time well you know again
different levels you know talent can be
you know running and jumping that's part
of talent but to me I I define it very
very broadly who plays Monday night
I like the favorites I like Michigan
State in Virginia and it just it just
feels like Spartans it feels like every
time they've had to figure out a way
they figured out a way and they're you
know sometimes it's a guy who hasn't
done much all season which has been the
case lately and just guys stepping up at
the right time it feels like Michigan
State's here yes McLovin I just want to
check in with Seth for a second I want
to make sure you know he Pat Purdue in
the Final Four I did by probably the
reason they make it B's Carson Edwards
was so brutally fouled at the end of
that Tennessee game oh goodness
[Laughter]
not this is not subject to debate it is
a fact that he was found
McLovin you have 20 second he may not
like the rule though technically he may
have been fouled but it was such a soft
called technically there's 500,000 words
he was fouled
yeah but you don't call everything if
you called everything you'd add 7,000
other words he was fouled according to
the week your honor please direct the
witness answer question yes or no was he
foul yeah no and what about the the play
that I tweeted you at the end the Duke
where the guy jumped into his knee he
didn't I mean
defender jump and by the way the reason
why you come out we take a break and we
just let you guys fight for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]